le diesel à moins d'un euro 40 le litre
en ce début d'année les prix des
carburants poursuivent leur baisse en
allant faire son plein ce matin joël
s'en est bien rendu compte
le gazole et l'a1 30,7 pour l'instant où
on va c'est vrai qu'il a un prix il a
bien défendu
là c'est bon survenue normal pour rien
dire d'autre
après faut voir comment ça va aussi
évoluer un on peut pas savoir
la baisse des prix ne concerne pas
seulement lui disent elles par rapport
au mois d'octobre le litre d'essence et
de gasoil ont perdu entre 16 et 18
centimes en cause le baril de brent qui
se vend aujourd'hui à 52 dollar contre
85 en octobre mais pour certains le
carburant reste encore trop cher ça a
baissé oui ça il ya des augmentations
derbesse des augmentations après celle
ces pressions encore suffisant pour
qu'il ya un réel ressenti dans notre
budget je mettais 50 euros il y à
quelques saria de trois ans je suis
passé à 55 euros de plein jeu passe à 60
là ça commençait vraiment est effrayant
donc la saillie sur bath est à 55
c'est rassurant mais ce n'est que
rassurant car pour le porte-monnaie
c'est pas c'est pas suffisamment bonne
nouvelle pour les automobilistes
les prix à la pompe devraient continuer
de baisser au moins jusqu'à fin janvier